un cours de chimie un peu particulier
dans cette classe du lycée emilie de
breteuil de montigny le bretonneux les
élèves extrait de l'huile essentielle
d'un clou de girofle sous les yeux du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer a tenu à visiter
cet établissement qui mène de nombreux
projets scientifiques
s'il ya tout un travail assez avant
gardiste qui préfigure un peu ce que
nous souhaitons au travers de la réforme
du baccalauréat et au travers de la
réforme des différentes filières et qui
est de réussir à donner des parcours
scientifique variées aux élèves sciences
de l'ingénieur ou encore systèmes
d'information et numérique
le lycée emilie de breteuil propose
plusieurs spécialités et formations liés
aux sciences encourager les carrières
scientifiques c'est notamment ce que
souhaite le gouvernement
sur ce thème le député de l'essonne
cédric villani a d'ailleurs rendu en
février dernier un rapport sur
l'enseignement des mathématiques dans
les témoignages qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
celui de cette enseignante qui disaient
certains élèves qui se pensent move et
en mathématiques sont quand même de bons
programmes heures alors que ce que
demande la programmation c'est de la
rigueur de la logique de la
compréhension exactement ce qui est à la
base de l'enseignement mathématiques
lors de cette visite le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est également
entretenu avec la communauté éducative
sur la réforme du baccalauréat dès la
rentrée 2010 8 les élèves qui entreront
en seconde ne devront plus opter pour
une série mais pour des disciplines de
spécialité